[Musique]
pour recevoir tous nos amis
bonsoir nos amis alors quoi de neuf
aujourd'hui mon petit doigt ne me dit
rien du tout il n'est pas bavard
j'espère quand même que vous avez été
sages je m'en vais voir ça de plus près
il ne traîne pas trop nounours ouais bon
pape hop hop hop hop hop hop hop hop hop
hop hop hop on est jeune chauffeur oui
vous vous arrêterez un pari bien madame
on me dit tu viens avec nous n'annonçons
pas dans la lune ou non non non non bien
le bonsoir
et puis c'est un autobus a les joueurs
jeudi
bon bah j'aime mieux ça pour la station
l'une monsieur c'est vingrau francs au
nom c'est cher c'est trop cher
bon bon mais si vous avez un autre arrêt
je préfère descendre
aion c'est un but il est très pratique
et et vous ou allez vous dont la petite
dame
avec ce beau panier mais oui
qu'avez vous dans votre panier petite
dame rien du tout mais ce à féron rôle à
temps ben ça c'est un chat s'il a plus
de quatre ans il faut payer sa place et
contre le sida château je crois bien que
je vais conduire cet autobus comme c'est
moche mais si mais si mais si vous voyez
ulysse mme le confirme
allons-y le moins bon
premier arrêt attention je ferai
[Musique]
dodo demi mais un bon soir minerve
à demain saluant voitures s'il vous
plaît on en
et maintenant terminus tout le monde
descend station god oh oui le nom fausse
couche
je suis là
bonne nuit les enfants à demain vanino
ce domaine aux émirats belle nuit
[Musique]
il
et maintenant en effet direction au dodo
pour tous les petits enfants car il est
tard il faut aller dormir embrasser bien
fort votre papa et votre maman et faites
de beaux rêves en route fidèles
compagnons venus les enfants à demain à
demain
[Musique]